>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," AT 11:00 A.M.
EASTERN TIME THIS MORNING
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER MADE A RARE PUBLIC
APPEARANCE READING FROM A
PREPARED STATEMENT FROM
BEHIND A PODIUM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
MUELLER EXPLAINED THAT HE
WILL NOT TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS, WHY?
BECAUSE HE HAS GOT NOTHING
MORE TO SAY.
IT'S ALL IN THAT 300 PAGE
REPORT WHICH CAN YOU READ
ONLINE IF YOU FEEL LIKE IT.
SO WHY BOTHER GIVING THE
SPEECH IN THE FIRST PLACE?
WELL, ROBERT MUELLER HAD A
MESSAGE HE WANTED TO
DELIVER.
NOT A MESSAGE FOR YOU OR ME
OR THE REST OF THE AUDIENCE
AT HOME BUT A MESSAGE AIMED
AT A VERY SMALL GROUP OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
WASHINGTON.
YEARS OF INVESTIGATIONS
COULD NOT PRODUCE A CRIMINAL
CHARGE AGAINST DONALD TRUMP
BUT, MUELLER SUGGESTED,
CONGRESS COULD STILL STEP
IN.
>> THE OPINION SAYS THAT THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES A
PROCESS OTHER THAN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
FORMALLY ACCUSE A SITTING
PRESIDENT OF WRONGDOING.
>> Tucker: A PROCESS OTHER
THAN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM, END QUOTE.
THAT'S HOW A 74-YEAR-OLD
ANGLOPMILE MIGHT DESCRIBE
IMPEACHMENT.
IT DIDN'T TAKE LONG FOR
DEMOCRATS TO GET THAT
MESSAGE.
THOSE WHO HADN'T BEEN
CALLING FOR IMPEACHMENT GOT
ON BOARD IMMEDIATELY.
KAMALA HARRIS OF CALIFORNIA
WHO IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
TWEETED THIS, QUOTE:  WHAT
ROBERT MUELLER BASICALLY DID
WAS RETURN AN IMPEACHMENT
REFERRAL.
NOW IT IS UP TO CONGRESS TO
HOLD THIS PRESIDENT ACCOUNT
BEING.
WE NEED TO START IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
IT'S OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATION.
BUT O'ROURKE TOOK A WHILE
FROM SKATEBOARDING TO AGREE
THERE MUST BE CONSEQUENCES,
ACCOUNTABILITY AND JUSTICE.
THE ONLY WAY TONE SURE THAT
IS TO BEGIN IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
AND THEN FROM THEIR SEATS ON
CABLE NEWS SETS ACROSS NEW
YORK CITY AMERICA'S OPINION
GENERATING CLASS APPLAUDED
HEARTEDLY.
>> THIS WAS VINTAGE BOB
MUELLER, NO QUESTIONS, NO
BULL.
>> HE SPEAKS IN MEASURED BUT
CLEAR TONES AND STYLE.
>> THAT'S THE MAN BOB
MUELLER IS.
HE IS PRECISE.
HE'S FACTUAL.
HE'S ACCURATE.
>> THE MAN DOESN'T KNOW THE
DEFINITION OF HYPERBOLE.
>> THIS WAS A SERIOUS MAN
MAKING A SERIOUS POINT THAT
THE FRAMERS GAVE US A WAY TO
ADDRESS A POTENTIALLY
LAWLESS PRESIDENT.
>> I THINK A LOT OF US HAVE
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
MUELLER.
HE HAS WORKED VERY HARD AND
DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB.
>> Tucker: MAN, CAN THEY
SUCK UP WHEN THEY WANT.
TO SAY A MAN NEVER STANDS SO
TALL AS WHEN HE STOOPS TO
KISS A BUTT.
THAT'S THEIR MOTTO.
UNBELIEVABLE.
CONFUSED LISTENING TO ALL
OF, THIS DEMOCRATS ARE
DEMANDING AS YOU SAW THE
PRESS STRONGLY AGREES WITH
THAT.
THEY LOVE ROBERT MUELLER,
WHAT WOULD THE CRIME BE
EXACTLY WHAT WOULD THE
CHARGES BE IN IMPEACHMENT
PROCEEDINGS?
RUSSIAN CLOTHES THE CORE
CHARGE AS MUELLER HIMSELF
CONCEDED THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE THAT EVER HAPPENED.
>> THE FIRST VOLUME OF THE
REPORT DETAILS NUMEROUS
EFFORTS EMANATING FROM
RUSSIA TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION.
THIS VOLUME INCLUDES A
DISCUSSION OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN'S RESPONSE TO THIS
ACTIVITY AS WELL AS OUR
CONCLUSION THAT THERE WAS
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE TO
CHARGE A BROADER CONSPIRACY.
>> Tucker: INSUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WAS NO
CRIME.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
THE SAME IS TRUE FOR
OBSTRUCTION BY MUELLER'S OWN
ADMISSION AFTER TWO YEARS HE
AND HIS SUBORDINATES WERE
UNABLE TO FIND A CRIMINAL
ACT.
>> THE REPORT DESCRIBES THE
RESULTS AND ANALYSIS OF OUR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
INVESTIGATION INVOLVING THE
PRESIDENT.
IF WE HAD HAD CONFIDENCE
THAT THE PRESIDENT DID NOT
COMMIT A CRIME, WE WOULD
HAVE SAID SO.
WE DID NOT, HOWEVER, MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER
THE PRESIDENT DID COMMIT A
CRIME.
UNDER LONG STANDING
DEPARTMENT POLICY, A PRESENT
PRESIDENT CANNOT BE CHARGED
WITH A FEDERAL CRIME WHILE
HE IS IN OFFERS.
THAT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
IS PART OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND BY REGULATION,
IT WAS BOUND BY THAT
DEPARTMENT POLICY.
CHARGING THE PRESIDENT WITH
A CRIME WAS THEREFORE NOT AN
OPTION WE COULD CONSIDER.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT KNEW
THAT IN FACT, JUST TO BE
CLEAR PROSECUTORS IN
CIVILIZED COUNTRIES DON'T
PROVE PEOPLE INNOCENT.
THEY DON'T NEED TO DO IT.
THAT'S THE STANDING
PRESUMPTION THAT ALL OF US
HAVE BY VIRTUE OF OUR
CITIZENSHIP.
INSTEAD, PROSECUTORS LOOK
FOR EVIDENCE OF GUILT.
AND IF THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
OF GUILT, THE PERSON IS
DECLARED NOT GUILTY.
THAT'S HOW OUR SYSTEM WORKS.
SO WHEN MUELLER SAYS HE
COULDN'T PROVE THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T COMMIT A CRIME, IT
WAS ON ADD STRIKING AND
BIZARRE THING TO SAY.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE
EVIDENCE MUELLER GATHERED
DID NOT SUPPORT CHARGES OF
COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
YET, MUELLER WOULD CLEARLY
LIKE TO SEAT PRESIDENT
IMPEACHED ANYWAY.
DEMOCRATS ARE LIKELY TO TAKE
HIM UP ON THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO ASSESS
ROBERT MUELLER'S REMARKS